here's what would happen if you fell off  the world's tallest building at over 800  meters the Burj Khalifa in Dubai is the  tall building you'd be falling off of  after less than six seconds into your  free fall you'd reach a terminal  velocity of about  240 kilometers per hour as you continue  to fall you'd feel nauseous and most  likely pass out from the speed and the  anxiety of the situation then you'd hit  the ground and die instantly in fact  you'd be hitting the ground at such a  high speed that there would be probably  nothing left of your body  unfortunately there's no real way you  could survive this fall unless you  somehow packed a parachute so